hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to medieval engineer now as
a former engineer or former engineer
considering that I didn't finish school
and never actually got my diploma and
I'm not actually okay well now I'm sad
and I was gonna start this off with such
a happy peppy mood but now we're gonna
relive my dreams as a medieval engineer
whatever the hell that means so the pole
principle of this game is is like an
open world thing where you build and
craft castles and machinery and you get
to destroy things it's all custom-built
you do what you if your imagination
tells you to build something you build
it you [ __ ] so I dabbled with this just
a little bit I dabbled on my own I
didn't know what I was doing but I
dabbled just a tiny itty bit on a custom
world it didn't make a lot of sense to
me and I don't know how to do it because
the resource system is intense and the
AI didn't work very well so what I'm
gonna try to do is I'm gonna explore
some worlds maybe go to multiplayer
because I don't know if there's gonna be
anybody that wants to help me ah there's
no one online ahh
this game is dead oh [ __ ] there's no-one
playing there's just one guy playing and
he's on a private server well [ __ ] I
guess I'm on my [ __ ] own time to make
a custom world cuz I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing who houses liens yes old
reactors large terrain normal terrain
small terrain eerie small terrain I
don't know what any of these is I
haven't played the game I don't know I'm
gonna open it to the public not that
there's gonna be anybody online but I'm
gonna do it do I want like a bonkers
day/night cycle yeah okay let's go let's
uh let's have some fun here maybe like
nights like just a flash in the pan
nothing night nights just like whoa that
was that night always [ __ ] name is I
need friends please I'm so lonely so the
whole principle is game is freedom and
creativity of those which I do not have
I I don't possess those elements so I'm
gonna go into this blind and hope for
the best cuz that's what I'm gonna do
hello this is me is that me oh is that
me I mean I'm a my the king or a mine
engineer I don't know which oh I got
inventories hello hi sir do I bow I'll
actually cut myself
well that joke wasn't worth it oh great
Wow look at that it crashed
oh well what [ __ ] me here we go
okay it saved it okay fan we're old I
need friends is loaded okay so ah
there's multiple statues I don't see any
trees I got a problem right off the bat
there's no [ __ ] trees where the [ __ ]
are the trees there's nothing oh there's
a whole lot of nothing ooh why am I here
I'm so lonely [ __ ] that okay that that
didn't [ __ ] work let's try that again
one with trees and such even like even
small terrain has some trees okay I'm
gonna do normal terrain oh that's much
better
I like this a lot oh no it's a statue of
crashing away from here so you can get
BOTS is the most important thing to do
to understand here and the bots can
become wood cutters and miners and
porters which are important for
transporting your [ __ ] so what's
gonna happen here is I need to make
servants so
I don't know what I'm doing but I think
I'm creating life huh hello Cedric I
Baxter hello Colin hello Luke
hello Berwick okay everybody had a
normal name besides you Berwick oh good
I need friends have saved that's good
man you are you giant or am i small
don't say I'm short you look at me in
the eye Luke tell me I'm tall Luke say
it
ah don't look away okay so so what if
all my AI bots are taller than I am in
my crowd I was crouching haha who's the
tall [ __ ] now it's me okay so I need
to set up a wood cutting area I'm a
Buddha wood it's a wood that's the wood
cutting area got an area for just
cutting of wood you got cut wood in the
wood area alright so and then Oh
oh jeez hey hey hey hey hey guys boys
boys boys boys come on now stop being
rowdy there's enough of me to go around
for everybody
oh man Luke is a hustling mining area
let's put the goddamnit you freaks
okay stock piles right there I don't
know how this works I've never really
done this just stop stop trying to suck
my dick stop staring at my balls Luke
you're a porter or you're gonna be up
gonna be a porter Luke okay he's ready
to port so we need to wood cutters so
Cedric and Colin not Berwick no Berwick
you're gonna be no Berwick come back
here here you go
looky looky and then oh hi holy [ __ ]
Baxter okay Baxter go for it
go to the mining area give me some mines
and then Luke you better be porting up a
storm over there because I need
materials and I need them now tonight
already is this night this is what night
is I can't tell think I see some stars
who I do
it's so pretty this game is delightful
oh man it's always nice to stop yelling
at your children too pretty oh Jesus
the hell is that okay well that's
concerning Erlich what are you doing
over there are you are you angering the
the mountain gods oh geez good job
Baxter berwick Rick oh my god Rick is
one of these rocks fall and break your
neck
Rick berwick how many times do I got to
tell you you need to get ribs removed to
do that okay thank you Berwick no but
take these stones since mr. party man
doesn't seem to be porting them anywhere
why what what Baxter what are you thanks
sir it's it's not gonna work oh you're
not even holding it right oh my god I
hope I really hope that maybe maybe the
forest and cruise is gonna be a little
better off than this because holy [ __ ]
Oh Luke Luke Luke Luke Luke Luke Luke
Luke little buddy look are you going for
that log you can pick it up at any time
is this in your way
try not to hit you in I got it oh yeah
there we go it's a good lookout okay
[Music]
he's important nice okay all right Colin
how you doing is this in your way
Colin Colin don't try to hide from me Oh
God he's blended into the forest Luke
Luke you almost had it come on buddy
you can do it Luke yeah you just stop
standing over it when you're trying to
pick it up Luke Luke Luke Luke come on
there oh come on
no that's the proper picking up
technique does that use all of your
lower back
oh geez Luke I saw that don't try to
hide from me you know what I get a funny
feeling that I got to do a lot of this
mono e mono now and I don't know how
this is gonna go but I'm gonna try my
best
Judi epic resource gathering montage
yeah yeah this is the montage song me
and my boys are up in this valley for so
long we're gonna get rocks and Basham
all together and then we'll make a house
that'll stand forever then we'll go grab
logs from all the trees in the woods
oh no barbarians who are you who the
[ __ ] are you
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you where
did you come from
[ __ ] I know I'm hurt oh but he's hurt
more Oh eat a dick need a big fat dick
Oh
Oh No oh my oh that guy murdered my boys
oh well that sucks I guess we think I
didn't have an axe oh it dropped on the
ground oh okay he killed him and then
put all of his equipment in this pit
well that's rather sad but now I can
make new servants alright Jarrett and
Fredrik you're both gonna be porters
because I've apparently discovered that
I can't rely on anyone to do anything so
I got to do it all myself returning to
the epic resource gathering montage oh
no barbarians
over the hills they're gonna come and
tell us and take all of our stuff so we
gotta kill them first oh [ __ ] do is just
a bunch of school children now we're
murderers and have to fight that Holies
when they come for us and take up the
tale oh I hope they don't make us scream
and Wow alright so now basically what I
did is I made everyone a porter so that
they'll just porch it and then I'll
gather up the resources inventories full
nevermind I can't do that hey anybody
want to pour it up some of the you know
other stuff no okay you're just gonna
put it okay it's gonna it you literally
how much wood is rolled down the hill I
see a log down there Oh God so this is
besides the point what we need to do is
we need to build [ __ ] stone ax timber
wooden sticks ah wooden railing for
safety wooden wall whoo Dan stairs
linked how world oh this is gonna take a
while I can do this okay I can do this I
can build okay okay
I have no Tim oh I don't have anything
that I need how the Frick do you build
something then oh I can craft
Oh oh that's handy okay that's how I do
that thing
oh there's crafting my inventory is full
[ __ ] and eat these mushes that's gonna
be good that probably that probably
tasted really good
I mean I'm in trouble I need a log I
thought I had log
I'm gonna build a campfire and put some
logs in it's over three that right there
hell yeah need large stone to build upon
I have large stone you talking about I
have it right there large stone I got -
I got it oh hi hello friend ow goddamn
it my face help help help
look Jared help no don't go after Colin
you dick hey hey ow
[ __ ] he's gonna kill me oh you sack of
[ __ ]
think you could take me huh huh you know
huh ah I got beat to [ __ ] oh my boys oh
I'm at my cart [ __ ] this I'm coming boys
boys I'm coming I'm coming
don't die don't die boys oh he's gonna
kill them all oh jeez Oh Oh No
Oh to her gone Oh God oh he's right
there
who is devastating him oh and I'm out of
stamina goddamn it okay I'm gonna pause
barbarian you better not be hitting
Jarrod Jarrod Jarrod oh you won't take
my boys for me you will take my boy for
me yeah that's right Oh your dad god
dammit [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you dude with
no neck you you killed my boys I'll
never forgive you even though you're
dead now all right how does okay how do
i how do I need build a goddamn how do I
build a goddamn all my stone is gone all
my stuff oh I saw it it was right here
where to go there it is okay give me
that stuff give me these now I need to
craft more wooden stacks I don't know
why the music is still playing I better
not be under attack soon oh I need a
crafting table Oh
oh that makes sense
okay good put down a crafting table put
that in rube okay that's good right
there and then I don't need to craft
anymore stop that get out of my image
get good good good ok so now that I got
the crafting top now that I got the
crafting table how do I now we're
cooking
and now over cooking but now we're not
cooking because I can't make any of
these well I have I have wooden sticks
right there
they're right there oh I need to put him
on the crafting table oh that makes more
sense
vlog about stones how about stones
how about stones foliage how about small
stones Wow what can I build now now
we're getting into it now we're doing it
alright I don't know how to make a
trebuchet oh but maybe I can make a
house oh yeah oh I can do that
oh hell yeah okay I'm gonna unlock this
oh I'm gonna make a chair nevermind I
thought I was gonna unlock that but okay
and now with my newfound genius I shall
rotative oh god I have made chair how
the [ __ ] do I sit in this
oh [ __ ] BAM I have made chair everybody
bow before my power of chair why is this
here when was it get down nature you
don't belong here
oh okay nevermind that's not gonna go
anywhere apparently alright so now I
need to make a wall I need to make a
wooden floor first we need is we need
one of these I can't see what this is is
this anything why is it so low into the
ground what what okay
and bam good enough but it's not done
cuz I don't have enough timber or no hmm
but I can make walls that's what I can
do that's definitely what I can do and
that's exactly what I'm gonna do
everybody watch BAM oh [ __ ] it's it's
dark I'm not gonna be able to get these
defenses up before my boys get destroyed
I need sticks
I think mine I think man oh [ __ ]
well tits good thing it's almost over
already clear Garth Brandon can I
communicate with them I need friends so
badly how do I communicate with people a
shortcut for that I'll look that up
controls systems one no systems to know
is here oh that's not that's not him
that's a barbarian
oh there's multiple barbarians j-turns
dead doors brandon where are you at
oh god oh god they're murdering Colin
there's nothing I can do there's so many
of them rather so many of them that
better not be Darth Brandon this Darth
Brandon's doing oh he's flailing wildly
Oh
oh god what are they doing ah they broke
my chair Oh screw you [ __ ] you all
deserve to die
ow not enough stamina I guess I gotta
take my beatings stalks fiddle I just
wanted to fall right into my grave ah
alrighty then I just want to kill these
guys and I'm gonna they are they bashing
on my table what do I need for a table
I'm gonna build the counter want this
way I mean two logs okay well I'm gonna
come for you I'm coming for you guys
well you think I don't know how to do
huh you think yeah go get revenge for my
bones yes I did yes I got more than two
okay I'm gonna go up on my Hill and you
guys are gonna get it just as soon as I
catch my breath Maps stamina ah you guys
gonna get it I hope you all line up in
one just put your hands one in front of
the other for me that will really do me
a lot of favors I mean you killed all my
children so I I'd hope you'd be willing
to do me some favors here gonna put the
wooden sticks in here put the small
stone in there make one of these cross
burrs oh they're getting close get it
hit it bang boom boom [ __ ] how do I
reload oh jeez gonna reload yeah oh jeez
haha [ __ ] that's what you get oh jeez
come on Oh smacked you right upside your
head all we had more crossbows that guy
literally had crossbows Wow and a hammer
Wow
I'm an idiot oh I'm not an idiot how
would I have known but still I'm an
idiot that guy's got shrooms I'm gonna
eat them all oh just one guy left well
time for some long-range and twitching
pull this is my dead dance tell my
family fuck'em I eat all your roots
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay what the [ __ ] alright
so I guess I'm all done here I have no
idea what the [ __ ] I'm doing but it is
looks like it has potential but this is
no one playing it so either way that is
all for medieval engineers right now
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know if you want to see another
one of these I don't know what I could
possibly do besides actually build a
castle maybe or build a machine but who
knows so thank you again and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]